la mort de gilbert bécaud ce matin à
paris d'un cancer du poumon hommages du
monde des arts ou chanteurs survoltée
qui a marqué les années 60 et 70
gilbert bécaud avait 74 ans on reviendra
longuement sur sa carrière ses tubes et
sa personnalité
des milliers d'un terne dans les rues de
paris mais cette manifestation nationale
marque sans doute la fin du mouvement
dans la plupart des grandes villes on
s'apprête à voter en effet la reprise du
travail
le feu vert des dirigeants afghans à une
force internationale de 5000 hommes
voici celui qui la dirigera le général
britannique john mc caul la france est
prête à fournir 800 soldats à tora bora
la traque de ben laden continue grotte
par grotte des billets de train à moitié
prix pour les fêtes de fin d'année il
s'agit d'éviter la traditionnelle
hécatombe de décembre sur les routes
on fera le point aussi sur les campagnes
contre l'alcool au volant
bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
son vrai nom était françois 6 et on le
surnommait monsieur cent mille volts
parce qu'il était une bête de scène
comme on dit gilbert bécaud avait
commencé par un coup d'éclat en 1954 en
provoquant une émeute à l'olympia bien
avant les pop stars
presqu'un demi siècle plus tard il
continué à chanter il n'avait jamais
raccroché
la maladie l'a donc emporté ce matin
gilbert bécaud une voix un tempérament
évocation jean jacques dufour l'olympien
cette salle de velours corail où il a
fait ses débuts en 54 p cole a toujours
abordé survoltée un truc de tracker pour
balayer la peur qui le saisissent et
avant de chanter et qu'il ne l'a jamais
quitté j'suis craque puis trop émotif
alors évidemment à chaque fois je ne
peux pas m'en débarrasser
un vent de panique alors les mains sur
le piano seul famille tôt il attaquait
toujours sur un rythme endiablé
il donnait envie de danser et même de
tout casser dans les années 50 en
l'écoutant les jeunes se déchaîner
champignon atomique beccu c'était mr
dynamite
mais tout cela c'est le passé et il
n'aimait pas vraiment les vos clients
vous savez moi je suis pas très
passéiste je suis pas très très fière
yesterday et je suis plutôt de demain on
nous pose souvent la question je sais
combien de valmont je vais quand même
disent que c'est pour une chanson je
pourrais le savoir bien sûr mais ça
m'intéresse pas ce qui maintient chez
j'aurais le temps d'en faire encore
quand même génial mélodiste deco a
composé plus de 400 chanson la plus
célèbre c'est peut-être est maintenu en
tout cas la version anglaise what now my
love fut interprétée par des dizaines
d'artistes dont sinatra et barbra
streisand
de toute façon en anglais ou en français
bécaud c'est une partie de notre
patrimoine
pour gilbert c'est pas très important si
les patrimoines robeco peut-être mais
pour gilles vergy pas le même et
s'habille d'un pantalon instinctif et le
calculateur deco ne faisait pas de
concessions la mode
d'ailleurs sur scène il ne mettra jamais
autre chose qu'un costume bleu et une
cravate à pois
on a chacun de petites manies et moi par
exemple quand je ne suis pas peu
maquillée et habillée avec mon costume
bleu et cravate à pois je me semble pas
à même de chanter en fait toujours un
costume bleu et cravate à pois à jean
ferrat
ouais
je
affirmant n'avoir jamais connu de bide
il parlait de la scène mais quand il
saura pourtant dans la production
d'oeuvres musicales plus ambitieuse en
60 de son opéra daran fut éreinté par la
critique
les chefs 8 pas mal mais ne restera
qu'une ombre au tableau pas de quoi
assombrir la formidable partition d'un
artiste dont les chansons nous ont
enchantés
avec ses mélodies tendres ou légers
hervé caux nous a souvent donné envie de
chanter
alors adieu l'artiste et merci grâce à
vous on a souvent été moins triste oui
gilbert bécaud a marqué par sa voix et
son goût de la scène on l'a entendu il
était aussi un grand mélodiste servi par
des paroliers inspiré quelques uns de
ses plus grands tubes avec georges bigot
well as
laissez tomber
pour courir
r contre lui
pour couvrir d'autres fortunes
l'important l'important
c'est la rose
cooptant
c'est la rose pourtant c'est la rose je
crois
tonton jolie ballade à c'est la balade
c'est la balade dans second jolie malade
elle c'est la ballade de table le coeur
même des signes dans le soir la forme
d'un espoir
il ressemble à tongres
mais même quand elle tremble de fièvre
c'est de nos amours brèves qu'elle se
souvient encore
mes mains caressent dans leurs droits
derrien venant de toi cherchant un peu
de joie énorme
je vais je faire pour qu'elle nie
puis sera ma vie du malaise chez la
terre entière waters sur toi ça faisait
longtemps que je n'avais pas eu un petit
oiseau dans ma rue je ne sais pas ce qui
m'a pris
il faisait beau être seul et suivi le
petit oiseau toutes les couleurs le
petit oiseau de toutes les couleurs tu
m'emmènes des ou dû m'entraîner
la facilité tic attend de moi comme
dépressive tard avez-vous lit là où tu
vas me jetais avec toi
dace riduze ça n'existe pas dans la
solitude
ça n'existe pas
la solitude
ça n'existe pas la glace était devant
moi marché la kali il avec un joli nom
mon guide
la souris blanche manège de ces nains
pin et moi je sue et par ce froid
dimanche
elle parle et on fera ce soir la
révolution d'octobre
je pensais déjà après le tombeau
1 tous les renverrait qu'a fait mouche
ouah
tous droits de vote gars
ces chansons là chacun les a plus ou
moins en tête ceux qui sont venus lui
rendre hommage devant l'olympia ou
devant la péniche où il était encore ce
matin ceux qui se sont retrouvés dans
les magasins de disques ou ceux qui à
toulon se souviennent de l'enfant du
pays claude crespo
l'olympia c'était en quelque sorte la
deuxième maison de gilbert bécaud
en 1954 ses admirateurs et cassé des
fauteuils et lorsque cet établissement a
fait peau neuve en 97 il était encore au
rendez vous
comme ils le sont aujourd'hui pour
témoigner
de leurs émotions
la france est restée seule force brutale
de ma fille parce que ma fille tu
apprennes à ta vie je trouve que gilbert
bécaud avait beaucoup de talent qu'il
incarnait la vie et qui fait partie des
grands qui nous ont versé depuis des
années j'y vais avec août
l'idole de mon papa c'est vrai que il
représente vraiment le chanteur
populaire par excellence les fruits de
noël étincelles sur les marchés de
provence mais à toulon le coeur n'y est
pas rep leur et vous savez qu'elle était
toulonnais oui de ces blancs mais les
toulonnais sont en deuil messieurs dames
et quand le coeur est lourd une mélodie
parfois vaut mieux qu'un long discours
qui a volé à voler à voler l'eau frange
du mars à paris ce soir au ponton de la
péniche de gilbert bécaud un anonyme
leur envieront lympia j'avais quatre ans
j'en ai pas raté un seul
c'est comme perdre un membre de ma
famille mon père s'appelle gilles bien à
cause de lui on n'en veut toujours
d'ailleurs
ces symboles ringards
demain l'olympia un registre permettra
de recueillir les témoignages d'autres
inconditionnels
du chanteur disparu
hommage aussi des politiques pour
jacques chirac gilbert bécaud était
l'une des voix les plus fortes et les
plus entraînantes de notre temps lionel
jospin salue un compositeur sensible et
inventif qui savait électriser les
scènes roma surtout du monde de la
chanson marie-hélène bono les morts le
bas
le fait qu'il était cet homme de scène
comme ça extrêmement instinctif
pour un jeune artiste est formidable de
voir travailler quelqu'un de tous ses
amis
tous ses amis peur
c'est vraiment avec le pcot que j'ai
éprouvé plus de plaisir le plus souvent
où les plus grands succès les plus
grandes joies et c'est un type que je
peux pas oublier
je suis mort avec lui enfin j'ai suivi
sa mort en même temps j'ai rêvé cette
nuit qu'il était mort le pour moi
c'était un des tout premiers chanson
française sûrement des compositeurs le
plus important sinon le plus important
de tous parce que musicalement il a et
il a fait des choses vraiment très
éclectique et très intéressante
c'est un vrai créateur un vrai
compositeur monde entier pleure
quand je débutais je faisais mes classes
si je puis dire j'apprenais les accords
de ses mélodies comme celle de brassens
ou de brel oh je me souviens de deux
chansons magnifiques qu'on a peut-être
un peu oublié aujourd'hui comme le mur
et a toujours un côté du mur à londres
mes mains mes mains des signes dans le
soir
ah oui mais il a toujours eu le talent
aussi de choisir des paroliers d'un
immense talent
dans un grand champ et la somme et
beaucoup de petites chansons comme des
cailloux du petit poucet qui me reste
est réparti tout de même du panthéon du
music-hall france est une des seules
vedettes internationales réellement
c'est la mémoire broadway enfin me dire
que non
et
tous les jeunes chanteurs qui veulent
faire ce métier doivent un jour regarder
une classe celle d'un spectacle de béco
y comprendre ce que c'est les sa de
musique au début
mariée deux fois gilbert bécaud était le
père de six enfants dont une petite
laotienne adopté il ya neuf ans on l'a
dit il était né à toulon en 1927 dans
une famille de petits commerçants
mais c'est dans le poitou à la buissière
où il s'était installé qu'il se sentait
vraiment chez lui sur place christophe
de balorre avec beaucoup de tristesse
ce matin la buissière le verdict un
télégramme de condoléances pour la
famille de gilbert bécaud pour tous les
habitants bouleversé c'est un ami fidèle
qui disparaît il y a trente ans bécaud a
découvert son havre de paix un petit
coin de la vienne où il aimait vivre en
toute simplicité avec sa femme et ses
enfants quand on faisait le foot avec sa
petite note qui venaient nous voir à la
province sur les terrains de football
les gens disent et peco mais c'est
bécaud énoncé gilbert voilà gilbert un
ami pour beaucoup ici la fierté de la
région et ce soir une grande perte pour
tous côtés les morts
tous ses amis tous ses amis tous ses
amis pleurait
voilà le lieu et la date des obsèques de
gilbert bécaud seront connus demain
c'est ce qu'indique son argent son agent
charlet marouani à noter sur france 2 ce
soir là rediffusion après le dernier
journal d'un taratata spécial gilbert
bécaud enregistré en 1993
et puis nous reviendrons nous mêmes à la
fin de ce journal sur l'un de ses
derniers tours de chant c'était en 91
l'actualité sociale avec ce qui
ressemble à un baroud d'honneur sauf
coup de théâtre le mouvement des
internes devraient s'achever dans les
heures qui viennent
bernard kouchner vous le savez leur a
accordée le fameux repos de sécurité
mais nous n'irons pas plus loin at il
répété hier soir après quatre semaines
de grève la manifestation nationale
organisée aujourd'hui avait donc un
parfum de colère résigné sophie rodier
virginie travers une marche funèbre pour
rythmer le cortège les internes en fer
l'espoir d'aboutir à un accord avec
bernard kouchner un mois de
mobilisations et seulement qu'elle peut
avancer une prime de 5000 francs par an
et un repos de sécurité après chaque
garde des propositions bien en dessous
des revendications des internes
les négociations n'ont pas abouti
on axe et se france
tout va proposer en espérant que façon
dans l'avenir il ya d'autres choses qui
bougeront
venus de toute la france ils ont le
sentiment de ne pas avoir été compris
par le gouvernement notamment sur la
diminution du temps de travail des 35
heures nous on est des médecins au
travail 80 et on nous écoute m quand on
demande à travailler 50 arrêts à
crémines airs et au delà
avant de se disperser
les 3000 manifestants s'offre un dernier
coup d'éclat envahir le champ de mars
demain après les dernières assemblées
générales trois syndicats sur quatre
devraient signer le protocole d'accord
avec bernard kouchner grève aussi des
avocats 80% des 181 barreau français
touché aujourd'hui la plupart des
affaires ont donc été renvoyés motif
toujours le même
l'aide juridictionnelle versée par
l'état pour la défense des plus démunis
cela représente 1 milliard 700 millions
de francs chaque année
l'aide a été revalorisé récemment mais
on attend toujours les décrets
d'application la journée d'un avocat
commis d'office au barreau de lyon
reportage vincent fourcade philippe
pivert du prévenu qu'il va défendre en
comparution immédiate
cédric paillard est ne connaît pour
l'instant pas grand chose tout au plus
ce qu'il a choisi de bénéficier de la ji
l'aide juridictionnelle
l'avocat n'est alors plus payé par son
client aux revenus insuffisants mais
indemnisés par l'état
quand aujourd'hui un français sur quatre
peut bénéficier de cette aide le
gouvernement souhaite que demain l oms
concerne près du double plus de travail
en perspective les avocats sont d'accord
à condition que le montant de leurs
indemnités soient corrigés pour certains
dossiers il s'agit vraiment d'une
indemnisation a minima et elle est
effectivement sans rapport avec le
travail effectué et a effectué ce
mouvement de grogne nationale est
attisée en grande partie par les jeunes
avocats car l'essentiel de leur
clientèle naissante et donc de leurs
revenus provient des bénéficiaires de la
jce
mais les avocats s'insurgent également
contre la volonté du gouvernement de les
obliger à s'engager par écrit à faire
correctement leur travail
il s'agit d'une véritable défiance à
l'encontre de l'ensemble de la
profession ce qui reviendrait à penser
que jusqu'à ce jour
les avocats ne faisait pas du travail de
qualité et les avocats d'exiger plus de
moyens pour la justice
car si le nombre de dossiers est en
constante augmentation il ya aujourd'hui
autant de magistrats en france au début
du siècle dernier
consternation ce matin dans le quartier
de la citadelle à lille une dizaine de
voitures ont été incendiées dans la nuit
en deux endroits
pourquoi mystère mais les habitants
craignent qu'une banalisation du
vandalisme sur place anne mourgues
dominique maes au petit matin genre ne
peut que constater les dégâts
c'était sa voiture une grosse cylindrée
entièrement brûlées pendant la nuit
je suis écoeuré littéralement écoeuré
j'étais assuré au tiers rôle incendie
n'ayant donc c'est une perte sèche entre
rembourser de rien du tout et il est
loin d'être la seule victime
5h ce matin quasiment au même moment
dans le même quartier
une douzaine de voitures en flammes à
chaque fois semble-t-il
la technique est identique une vitre
brisée un papier enflammé jeté à
l'intérieur pour les enquêteurs comme
pour les pompiers l'incendié volontaire
ne fait aucun doute
les véhicules étaient bien bien c'est
pareil via bien isolée donc avec le
panda propagation c'est bien été deux
foyers distincts dans la résidence
chacun tente de comprendre
en vain le quartier était jusqu'ici
plutôt qu'un entendu des petites
une enquête a été ouverte mais pour le
moment la police n'a procédé à aucune
interpellation
au havre l'heure n'est plus à la crainte
mais à la protestation le maire rpr
antoine ruffenach demande une audition
au ministère de l'intérieur dimanche
soir un gymnase a été incendiée le
deuxième en trois mois
plusieurs autres installations publiques
ont été détruites de la même manière
depuis un an et demi sur place paul de
genève vincent bouffartigue
bonjour monsieur services de police avez
vous une petite entité simple routine
pour les hommes de la brigade
anticriminalité du havre nous sommes
dans le quartier de la vallée béreult
dans la ville basse du havre un quartier
plutôt tranquille d'habitude mais
dimanche soir un gymnase a été incendié
à quelques centaines de mètres de là
depuis le mois de septembre
de tels actes de vandalisme se
multiplient jusqu'à présent c'était
plutôt ici dans la ville hôte que la
situation se dégradait selon les
autorités le havre connaît une
augmentation de moins de 5% des actes de
délinquance c'est moins que dans
beaucoup d'autres villes de la même
taille mais le phénomène aurait tendance
à s'inverser
quick restauration rapide quick qui et
quels cas du reiki rester ici 3 4 ans
vous demande d'être de vandalisme
perpétrés au niveau des clients et de de
violence de la dépression dans le déni
il a été détruit cette année là voilà
vous avez une seule 2
et salles de sport qui a été brûlé
récemment
oui bonjour monsieur police nationale
une barre de fer les hommes de la bac
poursuivre leur ronde un autre gymnase
incendiée il ya un mois depuis ils ont
reçu le renfort de crs qui patrouillent
avec eux dans ces quartiers la nuit du
nouvel an ils seront tous mobilisés ici
comme ailleurs la soirée est
traditionnellement agitée à
saint-etienne deux jeunes de 20 ans qui
avait tenté d'incendier un bureau de
police en mars dernier ont été condamnés
à trois mois de prison ferme les deux
hommes étaient déjà connus des services
de police
image d'une saisie spectaculaire des
douanes de marseille 27000 contrefaçons
de vêtements de marque chemises jeans
casquettes ont été saisis dans un
entrepôt de la ville 15000 fologo
lacrost ont également été récupérés les
vêtements étaient fabriqués en asie du
sud-est est destiné au marché en plein
air de la région
l'afghanistan c'est un travail de fourmi
compte entamer les forces spéciales
américaines dans la région de tora bora
où il des grottes et des gorges à la
recherche de ben laden à l'écart des
journalistes certains marines ont même
tiré en l'air pour les éloigner les
forces anti-talibans elle aussi
ratissent la montagne agnès vahramian
autour de la base les grottes vide d'al
qaïda pas de galerie complexe où le
labyrinthe mais de simples cachent des
recoins des trous dans lesquels les
islamistes armés se sont abrités
à défaut de pouvoir combattre
trois semaines de pilonnage par les b52
ont laissé deux larges au cratère les
soldats de l'alliance du nord cherche
depuis hier dans les décombres des
indices de la présence passée du chef
d'al-qaïda maison ils soupçonnent
d'avoir fui avec sa garde au pakistan il
y en a sûrement qui sont partis là bas
il ya un contrôle à la frontière
chinoise nvc lighting notre dédé n'a pas
que l'on cherche partout dans la région
pour trouver les mots ne sais pas s'ils
sont tous corps s'il y en a dix vivent
d'amour elle est bonne nourriture pour
tenir cet après-midi les moudjahidine du
commandant zaman quitter la zone
en emportant avec eux quelques trophées
les troupes pakistanaises et des forces
spéciales américaines sur ce soir
déployés près de la frontière pour
chasser ben laden dont la maison blanche
reconnaît celle a perdu la piste par
ailleurs les bombardements américains se
poursuivent autour de tora bora il y
aurait eu 138 sortie d'avion hier
et puis on connaît maintenant avec
certitude l'identité de l'interlocuteur
d'oussama ben laden sur la cassette
vidéo diffusée jeudi
il s'agit du cheikh al chouaïbi a
dignitaires religieux saoudiens qu'une
blessure en bosnie herzégovine avait
paralysé il ne serait pas entré en
arabie saoudite depuis cet entretien à
washington la disparition de ben laden
n'est pas officiellement considéré comme
un revers nous avons toujours dit que
cela prendrait du temps disent les
autorités
écoutez le président bush l'année
dernière reçoit toutes sortes
d'informations qu'il est dans une grotte
qu'il n'est pas dans une grotte qu'il
s'est échappé il n'essaie pas échappé
tout ça c'est de la spéculation
quand la poussière se dissipera nous
trouverons où il est et il sera traduit
en justice à kaboul l'information du
jour c'est l'accord des dirigeants
afghans pour le déploiement d'une force
internationale qui devrait comprendre
5000 hommes déploiement à partir du 22
décembre sous commandement britannique
la france indique qu'elle est prête à
fournir 800 soldats comment ces hommes
sont ils accueillis par les chefs locaux
sur place jérôme baugnies patrick
desmure
ils se sont fait le plus discret
possible ces soldats britanniques depuis
leur installation à l'aéroport de bagram
pour ne pas froisser les susceptibilités
mais bientôt il ne se cacheront plus
général britannique john mc coll qui
commandera la force a réussi à
convaincre la partie afghane d'accepter
un contingent de cinq mille hommes à
kaboul où les commandants des
moudjahidine sont maintenant chez eux
leur semble à la confiance mais le
déploiement des troupes étrangères sera
surveillé de près nous sommes prêts à
accueillir tous ceux qui viennent pour
nous aider à reconstruire le pays
mais s'il interfère dans nos affaires
nous ne voulons pas d'eux nous avons
déjà versé leçon pour notre liberté nous
le ferons encore les commandants afghans
sont reconnaissants aux américains et
aux britanniques de les avoir aidé à
vaincre ce qu'il considérait comme une
armée d'occupation
les pakistanais et les brigades
islamistes de ben laden mais pour les
afghans la présence du contingent
étranger doit être de courte durée
c'est ici sur l'aéroport de bagram qui
arriveront d'ici à la fin de la semaine
les premiers éléments britannique
surtout de la force multinationale qui
aura un mandat difficile ici en
afghanistan car la chute du régime des
talibans est aussi synonyme de retour en
force des seigneurs de la guerre et des
commandants locaux une image de new york
enfin ce panache de fumée au-dessus de
la ville rappelle bien sûr le très
mauvais souvenirs à manhattan depuis
plusieurs heures un incendie ravage la
cathédrale saint jean l'une des plus
grandes du monde
le feu a pris dans la boutique de
cadeaux installé à l'intérieur pour des
raisons encore inconnues 200 pompiers
sont sur place
et puis toujours aux états unis on a
appris juste avant ce journal que la
justice fédérale a cassé la condamnation
à mort du plus célèbres condamnés
américain mumia abu jamal ce journaliste
noir de 47 ans ancien membre du
groupement terre noire avait été
condamné pour le meurtre d'un policier
meurtre qu'il a toujours nié
en vingt ans de détention il est devenu
le symbole de la lutte contre la peine
de mort aux états unis
plusieurs manifestations de soutien en
france notamment ces dernières années
dernière précision etienne leenhardt
vous êtes en duplex avec nous à
washington elle est importante cette
décision est passible d'appel
oui absolument cette information vient
juste de tomber donc il faut encore être
très prudent david en fait un juge
fédéral a considéré qu'il y avait été
saisi par une requête des effets des
défenseurs de mumia abu-jamal sur un
nouveau témoignage qui donc
l'innocenterait avait été saisi de cette
requête il a décidé que cette requête
était recevable il cela ne veut pas dire
qu'il va y avoir un nouveau procès mais
cela veut dire tout simplement que mumia
abu jamal qui était depuis 20 ans dans
le couloir de la mort en pennsylvanie à
philadelphie et bien ne sera pas
exécutée on attend d'avoir des détails
supplémentaires il va y avoir une
nouvelle audience qui devrait décider de
la nouvelle sentence qui sera appliqué à
mumia abu-jamal cela ne veut pas dire
donc il est innocenté mais c'est
incontestablement une victoire pour
toutes les associations à travers le
monde et notamment en france vous le
savez qui s'étaient regroupés autour
d'un collectif qui s'appelait free mumia
libéré mumia c'est une incontestable
victoire pour tous les gens qui se sont
mobilisés donc pour ce journaliste qui
est en prison depuis maintenant plus de
20 ans merci etienne retour en france
avec le côté sombre des fêtes de fin
d'année le mois de décembre a été le
plus meurtrier de l'année 2000 sur les
routes 721 décès d'où les opérations de
prévention exemple cette initiative
lancée par des pilotes du dakar
cela se passe dans le gard 2000
collégiens et lycéens initiés aux
dangers de la route avec tournage d'un
film et troupe de théâtre sur place
véronique ghiglione françoise masure
le choc est là sur scène mais il est
aussi violent de l'autre côté des
barrières que cette année l'accident un
peu à ce point là
enfin en ondes à corps et une guerre une
seule 3-2 au froid c'est plus croient
guère et alors que de [ __ ] que
débutera bien le monsieur il a pas dit
la moitié qu'il avait ce qu'il avait vu
qu'il avait un et il a tué le 20 ça et
là dessus et son idée dégueulasse par
essence très roulante poussée photo l'os
et des accidents mortels
ça peut vous toucher sa fille chez vos
parents ont pu pousser vos frères etc
soyez conscient de cela le discours est
clair il faut heurter les jeunes dans ce
qui leur est familier réduire un peu la
distance qu'il maintienne entre le
risque et après je voulais vivre un jour
les vicois moi j'avais fait l'amour
en renvoyant savez pourquoi on est là on
imagine vallée à leur place ils sont
habitués à voir les choses de plus dur
plus difficile le discours trop édulcoré
n'a pas tendance à les sensibiliser
chaque semaine 16 jeunes de moins de 25
ans sont blessés ou tués sur les routes
du gard un chiffre en constante
augmentation alors le message de ces
journées de prévention routière doit
passer sans retenue et pour ce 31
décembre le ministre des transports jean
claude gayssot promet les opérations
coup de poing contre l'alcool au volant
et puis la sncf est mise à contribution
les soirées les lendemains de réveillon
les billets seront vendus à demi-tarif
stéphane despinoy jean-françois chevet
c'était l'an dernier l'opération billets
à 100 francs pour le nouvel an avait
provoqué une belle pagaille des trains
pris d'assaut par des milliers de
personnes
cette fois pas de panique la sncf promet
deux fois plus de billets à moitié prix
mais il faudra réserver en théorie tout
est prévu pour éviter la cohue au
composteur même si au fond beaucoup plus
de place que l'année dernière
en fait les voyageurs vont s'étaler
pour voyager avec 50% de réduction il
faut partir le 25 décembre et revenir le
27 ou bien partir le jour de l'an et
revenir le 3 janvier pas facile de
passer le réveillon en famille s'il faut
attendre le lendemain pour voyager on
peut pas partir
la veille du réveillon et revenir après
le réveillon c'est pas possible ça vous
fait délaisser la voiture pour le train
a carrément surtout qui fait froid et
tout ça c'est moins dangereux le train
que la voiture 50% mais monfils paraît
de toute façon par la promo de fin
d'année ou pas il reste tout de même
laisser pisser monnier mettra marche dès
ce matin les premiers billets à moitié
prix se sont vendus comme des petits
pains reste à savoir si les premiers
concernés les automobilistes seront
nombreux à en profiter
politique avec cette polémique suite aux
propos de jean-marie messier le patron
de vivendi universal qui s'exprimait
hier à l'occasion du rachat de la
société de télévision américaine usa
network a estimé que l'exception
culturelle française était condamné
indignation des professionnels du cinéma
et de catherine tasca ce soir la
ministre de la culture se dit scandalisé
par exception culturelle vous le savez
on entend le système des aides à la
production cinématographique française
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
l'adoption définitive de la loi sur la
corse
un premier vote très serré avait été
contestée on a dû revoter adoption
finalement par 249 voix pour et 2 128
contre et pianoteq le conseil
constitutionnel a censuré plusieurs
mesures de la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale notamment l'annulation
d'une dette de 16 milliards de francs de
l'état envers la sécu annulation qui
était destiné à financer les 35 heures
la présidentielle c'est confirmé un
quatrième candidat écologiste est en
lice brice lalonde a lancé sa campagne
aujourd'hui même s'il lui manque encore
des signatures j'évite imbert patrick
loi
on peut totaliser 25 ans de carrière
politique et retrouver les joies d'un
débutant devenir soi-même son affiche en
espérant que les électeurs ne vous ont
pas définitivement toute vie se passe
pas ma vie a frappé à la porte de 5
traceur disent regardez regardez je suis
là on ne sait pas si brice lalonde aura
du public mais la mise en scène est
soignée d'abord une péniche pour décor
comme rené dumont là le candidat
historique des écolos en 74 qui est
ensuite un héros pour mentor le
commandant massoud
alain madelin et françois bayrou le
revendiquer mais brice lalonde lui donne
ses interviews sous le regard du leader
afghan assassiné
la france est un art de vivre et
l'afghanistan est décidément à toutes
les sauces après la conférence de presse
buffet de produits locaux de la a
reproché à brice lalonde son
opportunisme de la lui rappeler son
parcours politique longtemps à gauche un
pas à droite est aujourd'hui au fait
qu'il faut évidemment très honnête est
formidable car on a une belle gueule
environnement familial
jaime gama de l'insas qui a des idées ma
job ariste année rare qualité
brice lalonde art pays dit-il 320
signatures d'élus il en faut 500 pour
être candidat ce matin l'humoriste
dieudonné lui aussi à la recherche des
paraphes est venu rendre une petite
visite à son concurrent
il est parfois difficile de distinguer
le spectacle de la politique à propos
d'écologie le gouvernement réunit demain
les associations de chasseurs pour un
débat qui s'annonce animé
il concerne les dates d'ouverture et de
fermeture et les quotas de gibier
rappelons qu'il y à un million et demi
de chasseurs en france dont 250 milles
de gibier d'eau chasse très pratiqué
dans la baie de somme reportage à
cayeux-sur-mer agnès monteux ludovic
tourte rien ne les empêchera de chasser
ni le froid et la glace ni les lois à la
tombée du jour les chasseurs installe
dans un hymne au d'élevage leurs chants
attirera les autres oiseaux nicheurs
souvent les précèdent prolonge la chasse
au delà du 31 janvier
ce que refusent les cuisines haut au nom
de la législation euros je peux importe
ici on a toujours chassé en février
attention ça m'aidera terre mais quand
les draps tachés nous avons pas droit
c'est ça il a des rêves fait pas les
gens de la nuit tombée les chasseurs
entre dans la nuque
on y parle de tout et beaucoup de
politiques la somme est un des fiefs de
chasse pêche nature et tradition aucun
d'entre eux n'accepte les nouvelles
propositions du gouvernement qui
permettrait certes d'élargir les dates
de chasse mais à condition de respecter
des sortes de cocteau exemple patrie
d'une oie cendrée par chasseur en
février vous allez tu vois par exemple
le 1er février
et bien vous pouvez ranger votre fusil
bon ça veut dire ça veut dire à un
moment donné que on nous laisse la
liberté de chaussée et la liberté de
chercher son cartouches en plein coeur
de ce territoire de chasse un parc
protégé le parc du marquenterre ici on
étudie ces oiseaux migrateurs l'idée de
quotas pour les écologistes c'est une
bonne base pour protéger les oiseaux en
période de reproduction
à condition qu'elle soit respectée quand
vous voyez le l'immensité du territoire
notamment en baie de somme ici
vérification en fait d une de chasse
prendre du temps il sera extrêmement
difficile
après 15 ans d'affrontements écologistes
comme chasseurs sont fatigués au fond
tous espèrent secrètement pouvoir
trouver un arrangement
opération coup de poing paris contre la
saleté dans les rues dépôt de sacs
poubelles en vrac crottes de chien
papiers gras l'opération se poursuivra
24 heures sur 24 pour une durée
indéterminée amendes sévères à la clé il
est vrai que la fermeture des poubelles
suite au plan vigipirate n'a pas arrangé
les choses ces derniers mois benoît
thevenet françois-xavier buts ou le
génie de la bastille a une vue
imprenable sur les déchets des rues
alentour ici un gobelet tendance
fast-food marine aux côtés de mégots
innombrables ou de vieux sachet un peu
plus loin un canapé chatoyant style
années 80 attend une improbable bnh
accru ses ordures petit monopoly du pari
pas propre
particulièrement le 11e jeu fera le 11e
salon madame parce que le 12e jeu sans
l'agacement ultime c'est bien sûr la
déjection canine qu'il faut condamner
ces deux maîtres chiens c'est comme un
enfant
enfin sur le point mais dans un coin de
paris un homme lutte seul il a décidé
d'en faire voir de toutes les couleurs
aux propriétaires des chiens qui
salissent les trottoirs de son quartier
chaque roth est signalé datée signée
show se dit artiste citoyen
l'objectif c'est de responsabiliser les
propriétaires de chiens qui se rendent
compte que on aura beau nettoyer et
mettre des millions pour nettoyer des
parts qui sont responsables mais à part
chaud et les enfants il n'y a plus guère
de parisiens pour prendre la chose avec
humour
l'image du froid ça va mieux en france
mais on évalue les dégâts près de lyon
des maraîchers se sont fait surprendre
ses cultures locales ont été détruites
par le gel ici les cardons légumes de la
famille des artichauts et qui se
consomme en période de fêtes c'est
dernière nuit le thermomètre est
descendu jusqu'à moins 14 intempéries
toujours en europe dans le nord de la
grèce une centaine de villages sont
bloqués par le froid
image insolite et la neige tombe depuis
trois jours en italie routes et
autoroutes bloquées en sicile et dans la
région de pescara
voilà qui nous amène autres tendances du
tourisme un secteur touché de plein
fouet depuis le 11 septembre
en tout cas certaines destinations
egypte ou tunisie par exemple
conséquences de cette crise les tours
opérators sont obligés de proposer des
voyages au rabais et même plus que ça
notre équipe a suivi un couple parti une
semaine en tunisie
le prix 990 francs ttc demi-pension et
vol compris reportage et le haut norgay
blesse grenier avant charter au dessus
de la méditerranée
direction la tunisie moins de 1000
francs par personne
c'est le prix que ces voyageurs ont payé
pour un séjour d'une semaine hôtel 3
étoiles demi-pension et avions compris
leur destination à ma m la deuxième
station balnéaire de tunisie didier
linda viennent d'arriver
c'est leur premier séjour dans un pays
du sud si elle a eu ses tarifs
ces tarifs aussi bas je serais jamais
venu les pays du maghreb où le maître
sir est pas du tout à la base quand moi
je suis plutôt pays du nord ont marqués
pour les températures la tabac dans les
souks lidié et linda sont quasiment les
seuls touristes
une tendance que les tour-opérateurs ont
cherché à inverser en lançant des
forfaits sur lesquels une ne gagne pas
d'argent c'est considéré comme un budget
de publicité ans
pour essayer de faire passer le message
volatilisé cette année calme qui offre
un excellent rapport qualité prix
comme didier les autres c'est l'heure de
la petite soirée folklorique c'est
joyeux vacanciers sauf que le prix de
leur séjour est une conséquence des
attentats du 11 septembre les moyens en
2001 un million de français à visiter la
tunisie
certains ont profité du soleil d'autres
des promotions une tradition provençale
qui avaient leurs deux porte bonheur les
treize desserts de noël déguster le soir
du 24 décembre raisins secs figues mais
aussi fougasse à consommer au retour de
la messe reportage à grimaud dans le var
au restaurant le mûrier mary pierce
amitié thierry breton ce matin sous le
soleil de provence le vigneron albert
cartel en reçoit la visite du chef jean
philippe dubourg car il paraît qu'on
trouve ici les meilleurs raisins de
table du var et en creusant un peu au
pied des ceps de vigne on déniche même
les barragan ces petits poireaux sauvage
de provence ses tresses est intéressant
c'est ce sont des produits qu'on trouve
dans la nature ici fois comme le thym le
romarin et ces choses là dans son
restaurant à grimaud le jeune chef
prépare la noël et fait chanter sa
cuisine comme chante les cigales
dans les cuisines provençal on apportait
les plus beaux fruits qui prend ce que
tu veux tu me vois ce que tu veux pas
vous aurait-il pas la marchandise et
après tu as toi je te dirai je dicte pas
je regarde pour fêter noël chaque
famille ici devra après la messe de
minuit partager c'est treize desserts
c'était si vous voulez une façon à
quelque part de porter bonheur
et tout le monde devait et se devait
d'être autour de la table pour les
treize desserts
c'était quelque part le commencement
d'une année d'une année sainte pour pour
les chrétiens s'étaient c'est un peu le
commencement d'une vie de famille pour
une année quoi raisin orange fruits secs
nougat et fougasses la fougasse que les
anciens appellent la pompe à huile
moi mes parents car c'est le doyen de la
famille qui le soir de noël fera donc le
partage selon la tradition provençale
images de football et de ce match avancé
de la 18e journée du championnat de
france le premier recevait le dernier
nantes a été défait 3-0 par lance le
premier but ici de sibierski un joli
retourné
la rubrique égalité des sexes quelques
jours après la nouvelle miss france et
l'élection de mister france 2002
l'heureuse élue mesure 1 m 85 pour 80 kg
et les centraliens il a 22 ans il
représente la région champagne a donc
été lui la nuit dernière par un jury de
personnalités présidé par paco rabanne
fin de cette édition à suivre la météo
patrice drevet l'info sur france 2 00h40
le journal de la nuit jean claude
renault dès 6h30 et les matins avec l
invité des 4 vérités piernas aux
chirurgiens 13 heures daniel bilalian
ans quitte avec gilbert bécaud c'était
en 91 chez jacques martin est maintenant
admis
je vais je faire
tout ce temps de travail
de tous les gens qui m'a dit fais
maintenant que tu es parti
je veux essayer
pourquoi pour cris
et ce matin
j'y reviens
pour rien
ce gars
kima
il
il marque reçoit
ça va